here's what would happen if a meteorite
crashed into your home
first a falling meteorite would slam
into the particles in our atmosphere
rapidly compressing the air in front of
it this would cause the meteorite to
Glow as it heats up to temperatures as
high as 1650 degrees if the rock hit you
you'd get a big bruise but surprisingly
much further damage if you were Brave
you'd pick up the meteorite only to
discover it's not as hot as you thought
it's just a bit warm since meteorites
are poor heat conductors then you'd
notice a bad smell depending on its
composition The Rock could smell like
tar wet hay or your compost your little
four kilogram Space Rock could be worth
more than a Tesla so